this is dangerous
[Music]
yo yo hey so alright here's the deal
here's what's happening
you guys might remember the video we did
a few days ago where Sam and I made a
bet about an Amazon delivery guaranteed
new day shipping that arrives I owe you
20 if it doesn't arrive on her before
the 30th then you owe me ten all right
he lost
sorry we missed you we tried we tried
yeah we tried
he still hasn't paid me he owes me $10
and today he's gonna pay because I am
going to be making the world's largest
airsoft rifle I'm gonna be stringing
together eight airsoft rifles hooking
them up to a single trigger and asking
Sam one simple question you want to pay
with cash or plastic in order to
construct the world's largest airsoft
rifle I've selected eight of our finest
m4 platform airsoft BB rifles now if you
don't know anything about airsoft these
shoot little plastic six millimeter bb's
at a velocity of about 400 feet a second
so they do hurt you should always wear
eye protection
Jake's building this airsoft gun project
and Jake took up all my nice game guns
I'm very protective of them because they
get ruined all the SUBSCRIBE time
anyways Jake went ahead and ruin one of
my guns already oh
he plugged my frickin white ball battery
and just a wrong battery charger now
stricken blowing up you know some I
didn't know that that was a special baby
baby charger so it's really hot right
now and it's swollen up
[Music]
just let it be it's not slow it's just
gonna turn you on the flamethrower it's
good until flamethrower but the [ __ ]
almost started on fire oh don't worry
guys I'm back from the desert I did not
find the lens whatever it's cool I'll
just get back to work where's my dad
[Music]
[Applause]
we were thinking about shooting till
about like 2:00 p.m.
oh he's gone he's got to do this now
it's just very dialogue it sounded heavy
where we need to you gotta make like
giving it's like new yeah we just need
that like commercial clean audio well
yeah but the problem is I today's my day
today or do we were scheduled to be here
i I didn't know sorry so we did he's not
just gonna come into the department have
been aware of this and he should have
told us this you know we know how to
roll with the punches here corridor
think about it well let's push the shoot
now so everything in this shoot so far
is pretty standard clean kind of flat
commercial lighting which is on purpose
but we have one shot here at the end I
want to make it a little more
otherworldly Danny is physically present
in the space but not mentally present is
he's sitting in a lighting environment
that's somehow not affecting him huge
window over there a lot of natural light
spilling in what we're gonna do is use a
reflector to block out the light it's
negative fill instead of reflecting it
that's gonna create a lot of shadow and
that's gonna allow us to control the
lighting there are some under light for
some spook there's some edge top light
for just a little bit of that rim
outline that's gonna make a big
difference it's gonna make the shot
stand out and seen since normally these
giant windows are just blasting light
through all right so I really should
have been doing this on shoes earlier
but what I really love about the red
cameras are all the false video color
modes so one handy feature on the Reds
that I really should have been using for
years but now we're finally using today
is the exposure toggle I have been using
it but today we're using it the right
way
check out the exposure toggle mode on
red it will show you what parts of your
frame are underexposed and which ones
are overexposed but what it also does it
has a green cast on everything that is
exposed for skin tones so if you're
seeing this green on here that means you
know your people and your skin tones are
perfectly exposed that's really handy it
allows your subjects to say very
consistent okay
do not get lost in the desert if you
lens Danny is actually moving on to new
and exciting things a lot of you
probably know this I have my own YouTube
channel and it's been growing really
well recently and working here and doing
that at the same time sort of felt like
it was becoming working two jobs at once
I felt like I wasn't really putting in
my full effort into either one of those
things and so the soldiers had to pick
one and so now I'm just devoting all my
time to my youtube channel I mean you're
moving away from Los Angeles as well I
hear that's a big city yes I'm also
moving to Illinois exactly yeah we don't
have a studio there yet someday maybe
I'm well Denny's been a pleasure Oh
once I selected my rifles I went through
made sure that they were all perfectly
functional then I brought them outside
to set up my firing range I used a
regular plastic folding table and then I
needed something to prop the weapons up
on I used an old monitor stand and a
piece of wooden door frame in order to
hold up all of the weapons I needed
something consistent across all of the
weapons in order to make sure that they
all are being secured from the same
place now that's why I selected all m4
platform airsoft rifles they all have
the same lower receiver meaning that I
could put a board at the front of the
receiver and then behind the pistol grip
at the back of the receiver and they
would all generally be secure after I
was able to prop them up I then used a
very simple screw and string mechanism
to basically just tie down the rifles at
the back and the front of the receiver
to tie down the front I use the
trucker's hitch Truckers nuts are good
when you have two anchor points and
you're trying to create tension when you
get to the second anchor point but you
have that problem where because you're
tied off to one you can't create tension
with the other a trucker's not reverses
the direction of pull so that you're
able to actually get tension between two
points
I'll show you first off secure your
anchor point so be my anchor point I
just tie this down like that and boom
there's my anchor normally without a
trucker's not I go over and then I go to
this second point I try to create
tension but as I go to lock it I lose
all my tension you make a little slip
basically you just make a little a
little loop make a little loop like that
you just tie a knot in the rope like
that then you go down to your anchor
point but then you come back I come back
through the trucker's not like that
right now when I do this it reverses the
tension so that I can secure even here
and then you put that around the same
anchor point and tie it tie it off yeah
it actually helps us a whole bunch so
it's way more secure
yeah barely budging then I tight strings
to all the triggers and ran those
strings back to a center point from
which I could fire all the guns
simultaneously Wow okay the the sheer
power of it is kind of intimidating and
you know in theory it's working let's
give a shot to people let's give it a
shot boys ready yeah
I saw every trigger move intense we have
a rule around here any time you're going
to fire a projectile at someone else you
must first fire it upon yourself oh dude
that's brutal look at that ah that that
this is this is dangerous freakin hurt
we should probably move it back that's
that's that's like not friendly anymore
that's not like haha that's like dude I
just I see you with an airsoft gun and
you you're literally gonna have a piece
of your tattoo Oh No yeah look that's
from an airsoft gun too look at that
it's already swollen this is kind of
dangerous now I need to go talk to my
friend Sam yo I order everything on the
Internet
that's why this video is sponsored by
Muhammad L these guys hooked me up with
a personalized stylus that picks out
your clothes for you and they picked up
my clothes today
and I'm gonna wear them let's see what
they give me they'll pick out your
clothes for you you can see it online
and you have 48 hours to say yes or no
before they send it and once they do
send it you have seven holes
to decide what you want to keep the more
you keep the more you save if you keep
four pieces you get 20% off if you keep
three pieces to get 15% off if you get
two pieces you get 10% off let's take a
look and see what I got today
so it's summertime here and I love
Hawaiian shirts and I like men in shirts
through this a very subtle floral print
linen shirt super cool tropical Hawaiian
socks just a nice t-shirt just some nice
shorts
let's try it out on oh my god it's green
oh hey if you guys like what you see you
can go to balm pill calm slash Sam and
Nico I gotta take their pants off I
don't usually do this on camera he's
floating hands I'm gonna keep these on
for the whole video that's Bo and the
FPL Oh calm nice classy shirt I like it
I'm saving the pants for last if you go
to Bob he'll calm slash Sam and Nico get
25 bucks off your first order that's
pretty cool thanks Nick yep you gotta
keep moving to sell the effect have you
ever put on a shirt and snap yourself
with one of these pins bomb tell told me
to wear this green suit so my body
wouldn't distract you and you can focus
on the clothes oh here we go
so now we have context oh my god I'm
starting to get hot how can I be hot
without a body it's what's inside that
counts
there we go yeah it's coming out it's
finally coming together
I knew they were going to send me green
shorts I'm sorry how do they do this is
the object actually I think this comes
down pretty well it goes well with my
Hawaiian shirts that pack has just saved
me a trip to the store check it out it
all fits it looks super nice the shorts
are green wait is this gonna keep wait
do you see I was probably once a little
weird I'm just gonna go up to him and
I'm just gonna say Sam you know that ten
bucks you owe me it's the time
it's time to look if you just gives you
$10 never carries cash let's yeah oh
you're bending oh you know I only accept
cash or flesh shot no about this look
it's not it wasn't hard and this the
million of airsoft guns sitting out that
you've been getting functioning well I
just thought many of you thought I was
getting them ready for a shoot it's it's
time man I tested it on myself I will
allow you to wear armor here here's the
thing Sam you can select as many friends
as possible to help you absorb the
bullets I didn't lose the bet then do
him this favor if he asks if you're a
true friend Wow are you seeing spring I
don't know if I should answer this
because it sounds like something's going
on okay just my Jason flexes the way he
said that no I'm not saying you're not
Sam's friend I have a feeling I know
what's going on Sam is my worst friend
yes but he is your friend
dude are you Sam's friend he's my boss
I'm saying friend when it comes to
hanging out but that never happens are
you Sam around today
I would I don't blame her we see the rig
[Music]
that's ridiculous
you go with your this and yeah well
that's sufficiently terrifying that is
the most murderous No
now what's your next project couldn't
rapture next on J dubs murder machines a
guillotine ray